Today, nearly one in 10
is food insufficient.
That number has been rising
every year since 2014,
and it's forecast to become
considerably worse
over the next two to three decades.
This is especially true for the poorer
countries of Africa and Asia,
where the rise in demand
is outpacing the rise
in our ability to supply.
I want to tell you
how the most important process
on the planet,
boosting that process, photosynthesis,
could alleviate this problem.
How photosynthesis works
is that plants remove carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere,
then they use sunlight energy
to convert that into our food,
releasing our oxygen at the same time.
Photosynthesis is the most studied
of all plant processes,
and from that knowledge,
we realize that even
our most productive crops
are only achieving about one fifth
of the potential efficiency
of that process.
As the most studied of plant processes,
we realize that the efficiency is low.
Now, if we look at other genetic
improvements of plants,
these have typically involved
one or two genes,
for example, the shortening
of the stems of rice and wheat,
allowing more of the plant's biomass
to go into the grain that we harvest,
was at the core of the Green Revolution.
That involved mutations
in just a few genes.
But photosynthesis is a process
of over 100 steps,
each of these facilitated
by a different protein
and in turn coded for by many genes.
So where do you start?
Well, you can envisage this
like a car production line.
Imagine you've got a thousand workers.
Where do you place them on your line
to get the most output?
Similarly, if you consider
the amount of protein in a leaf,
how do you distribute that
between all these steps
to get the maximum efficiency?
If you could work that out,
then maybe you could make progress.
However, to do this experimentally
with all these permutations
may take decades.
So instead, we built
a digital twin of the process
in which every one of these reactions
was described by a differential equation
producing a system that we could then
numerically integrate and optimize
to pick out where should we
be making changes.
So after three years
of building this system,
we are now ready to do
our numerical integration.
And it failed.
It failed miserably.
(Laughter)
Fortunately, another scientist
at our computer center
heard us talking about our problems
and said, "Oh, I had exactly
the same problem with my work
on balancing rocket motors,
and here's how I solved it."
So he looked at our problem and he said,
"Oh, this is more challenging
than what I'm doing."
And he worked with us.
And using his methods,
we were now able to numerically
integrate our system,
and we could optimize that,
and we could start to see places
where we might be able
to improve photosynthesis.
So that's just to tell you
that photosynthesis isn't rocket science.
It's harder.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Well, of course, models
can look very attractive.
But when you now have to go
into a muddy crop field
to show that you can actually do this,
it doesn't look quite so pretty.
But despite these challenges,
we were able to get together
a team of experts
from Australia, Britain,
China and the United States
to work together on this.
And this is how we work.
We use this digital twin to say, well,
what is the easiest change we might make
that would have a big impact?
Then we engineer that into a crop.
If in the greenhouse,
we can see that the genetically
modified plant is yielding more
than the unmodified one,
then we have the acid test saying,
does this actually provide a higher yield
on our experimental farm?
Now we've now made three different
changes to photosynthesis,
each individually increasing
yield by over 20 percent.
And I'll just tell you about --
(Applause)
A couple of these in a little more detail.
In one case, the digital twin said
a protein we call SBPase
should be far more abundant
in the leaf than it is.
So we put in extra copies
of the genes coding for that protein.
We made more of it,
we got more photosynthesis,
we got a higher yield.
Well, this was a bit
of a mystery because ...
This protein is a tiny fraction
of the leaf's total protein.
So why hadn’t evolution already done this?
A colleague pointed out to us
that the ancestors of our crops
evolved in the carbon
dioxide concentration
that is about half what it is today.
Aha!
So we reran the model
at this past CO2 concentration,
and we found now that the model was saying
well you don't need
any more of this protein.
So then we got curious,
what about the future?
In 2050, we're predicting
a considerably higher
carbon dioxide concentration.
When we ran it
at that higher concentration,
it said the benefit of increasing
this protein was even greater.
Well, we couldn't easily
remove carbon dioxide
from the air around our crop,
but we could add it.
And when we did this,
the model prediction was proved
that we did indeed get
an even bigger boost in yield.
So this told us that evolution
has just not had time
to keep pace with the changes we have made
in crop environments.
Now, another change
we've made in crop environments
is to grow our crops
at ever-increasing densities.
This means that there's a lot
of shading within the crop.
So over the course of a day,
the leaves are going in and out
of shade due to clouds,
due to the passage
of the sun across the sky,
but most importantly,
shadows cast by other leaves.
Now, for photosynthesis,
when the leaf goes into the shade,
it's rather like you
coming out of the sunshine,
going into the shade of a room,
and it takes time for your eyes
to adjust to that change.
The same is true of photosynthesis,
except it adjusts rather
more slowly than your eyes.
Over the course of the day,
this slow adjustment costs productivity
an estimated 20 to 40 percent.
So again, using our digital twin
and also other information,
we identified three proteins
that we should regulate.
So we added extra copies
of the genes for those proteins,
got more of them,
the leaves adapted faster
to fluctuations in light.
And in soybean on our farm
we got more than 20 percent
increase in seed yield.
(Applause)
So how do we now get
from these improvements
to seed
which will give greater yields
where it is most needed?
And I'll just give you
one ongoing example.
We've been working with TJ Higgins,
a plant biotechnologist from Australia,
who's been working in Nigeria
really for almost 20 years,
developing insect-resistant cowpea.
Cowpea is probably not
what you think it is.
Cowpea is actually a nitrogen-fixing crop
related to soybean,
and it produces, like soybean,
a protein-rich seed.
It is, in fact the most important
vegetable protein source in West Africa,
and it is often referred to
as the “poor man’s meat.”
A problem with cowpea
is that a pod boring insect
can completely destroy
a family's entire crop.
So TJ's ...
genetically modified cowpea
that is insect-resistant
is very powerful,
and TJ and his colleagues work
with governments in West Africa
to put in place regulatory frameworks
for genetically modified crops.
And now this insect-resistant cowpea
is available to farmers in Nigeria,
where it's become very popular.
This year, it was also released in Ghana.
So what we are now doing with TJ
is stacking our
photosynthetic improvements
on top of his insect resistance --
this is all royalty-free --
so that these farmers
will have access to seed,
which will produce a crop
which is insect-resistant
and delivers a higher yield.
So I hope I've shown to you that ...
by boosting photosynthesis
we can relieve the risk
of food insufficiency
for some of the most vulnerable.
We can protect the environment
by preventing the need
to go onto yet more land
to produce our food.
And the possibility that we might
even be able to remove carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere.
A 21-century Green Revolution,
one we so urgently need.
Thank you.
(Applause)